коктейлі молотова ставок якщо судді на
газу пакет реформ заробимо у неї
подалі та фінансову допомогу vds
парламентарій журавлина чи волає канону
досвітла шумові гранати ким і розганяли
масові акції протесту метати його за
якій форму створ це систему і
надає ногу боці б досяг о.ю.
та гранту в атоми пенсії для всіх мешканців
у греції замшу в боці this is тема буде
соціально справедливу поважає
субаре фінансів та розумом та 2010 року афіна
у 3 мани перший транш фінансову
допомога
але 73 мільярди євро 2 роки потім врахуй
по тому 140 мільярдів євро після сік
ті давати за честь заколов проти у
мосту них руки в вибух вибуху Греція
в дупу на 240 мільярдів євро в team
пам'ятних результатів поки не моїм
реформи йдуть з і скрипом
ваша повели некомпетентність і брехня
кожного дня до приховану регресію та
кожен день поки ви про влади Греція
натиснули idn однією з тієї околиці ще на
вигляд би вася і все парламент спалив пакет
реформ шляхом скоро дуже пенсії
залучення по-датськи до гречки влада мої
номери за врахує це і три з половиною
мільярда євро збирайся битви з чотирма
премії до 1000 поповнити бюджет ще
на пару мільярдів євро
реформа так вже поневолюють підвести не
понтяно повік у
там частому брюсселі міністри фінансів
україни член ваги червовий раз ми
малювали виділять дуже січні мільярди
євро на фінансову допомогу
передача посидючості точно рішення у
хвалять ви ж на прикиньте травень